[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous présenter collatéral
de Michael Mann donc c'est un film de
2004 écrit par Betty Michael Manon on
connaît beaucoup et on parle beaucoup de
son film culte heat avec Robert De Niro
et Al Pacino et du coup latéral est pas
dire qu'on sait comme un de ses films
peut-être moins important ça fait mon
graphie et en tout cas moi un des films
que je préfère on suit l'histoire d'un
chauffeur taxi Max qui prend en stop
Vincent je vais par Tom Cruise et qui
est au cours d'une nuit en fait de façon
à teinture un gage et qui a 5 arrêts à
faire et 5 contrats à réaliser c'est un
des premiers films après Star Wars
épisode 2 à utiliser une caméra
numérique pour quasiment intégrater
l'intégralité du tournage ce qui est
aujourd'hui voilà coulerait de source
mais en tout cas à l'époque c'était pas
le cas et notamment parce que Michael
man voulait rendre la ville Los Angeles
dans laquelle se déroule le film vous
les montrer la ville comme un vrai
personnage à part entière avec des
caméras avec en tout cas si le film
avait en pellicule on n'aurait pas eu la
profondeur de champ que qui souhaitait
on n'aurait pas vu la skyline aux soins
au loin on n'aurait pas du tout ces
lumières de la nuit là cette ambiance
très granuleuse du film et du coup le
numérique a permis ça donc malgré des
pionniers et des premières aussi à
essuyer les plâtres parce que c'était
pas les mêmes caméras numériques à
l'époque on disait aujourd'hui et voilà
c'est un film avec Tom Cruise à contre
emploi qui est absolument incroyable
dans ce rôle de tueur à Garches froid
méthodique on l'attend pas et pour moi
des meilleurs rôles de Tom Cruise et
voilà une vraie réflexion sur sur notre
humanité aujourd'hui sur notre
alimentation et sur notre isolement dans
les dans les grandes villes modernes et
un film voilà qui se passe en une nuit
une virée nocturne et que je vous
recommande fortement
[Musique]